changing the topic though like no i've i
feel like i've lived in japan for long
enough now that my opinions on certain
things have changed some things which i
started which i initially thought were
amazing
are now
like i i don't think are as good as uh
in british okay okay
eg
wagyu beef
okay remember the first time i tried
wagyu beef it's so over praised i'm just
like oh my god this is the [ __ ] i'm
sure a choice of beef it's a it's the
[ __ ] ferrari of beef and then you
live here for a year and you have equal
you you have easy access to it and i'm
just like i just kind of want a normal
ribeye now i just kind of want a normal
steak genuinely normal steak
is better because wagyu is just fatty
and if you like that you like that but
if you want like a really nice tender
cut of meat it's just so good michael is
good maybe like you know once or twice a
year i think like if you really want to
like treat if chris was here he'd be
he'd be like no no no i know the best
places
he's going to the wrong places when i
went to kyoto right with chris
there was this stand and we were kind of
hungry and the stan said there was wagyu
beef on a stick for like a thousand yen
yeah i was like no way is that wagyu
yeah no [ __ ] way and they had this
meat out on the counter like this
example me and i was like all right fine
we'll get it we'll try it we'll try it
and so they have this example meat of
what the meat looks like yeah and uh
it's like the fake kind um and so we
order it we pay the man and uh he pulls
out some mink from a cooler that is
definitely not wagyu it's literally like
the shittest cut of a beef you can
imagine right right literally impossible
to chew a dog would have trouble chewing
this thing right yeah and i was like
chris
i can't believe you thought this was
going to be real there's no way we would
get
wagyu steak on a stick for 1 000 yen
outside of the for the [ __ ] uh
kiyomizudero or whatever it was oh yeah
yeah yeah like at a tourist trap are you
serious chris i couldn't believe that he
fell for it and then he convinced me to
actually try it what a waste with that
we took like two bites and we're like we
can't eat this [ __ ] we threw it away
yeah well i mean because like i feel i
had the better experience because like
when on journey across japan we had that
exact same thing in takamatsu and it was
the hiragyu beef which is like it's like
a higher brand
that's that's that one was actually
delicious because you're not in kyoto
which is yeah basically it's turned into
a tourist gamble it's kind of you can
get some good stuff there but it's so
over tourist uh so uh i don't know you
gotta you gotta go like tourists yeah
you gotta go to like the back streets of
kyoto to get the good [ __ ] i thought
yeah that's that's where like not in
front of the goddamn temple to get wagyu
beef yeah because because i feel like
wagyu beef is something that you should
try as like uh as like a a rare thing
right because what i didn't expect was
how easy it would be to access it you
can buy it in the [ __ ] supermarket oh
yeah
like like it's it [ __ ] blew my mind
the first time i saw wagyu beef in the
supermarket where the only other time
i'd ever seen wagyu beef is like at like
[ __ ] high-end high-end restaurants
where you'd be paying hundreds and
hundreds of dollars for a few keys of
wagyu yeah and i remember before coming
to japan i'd only tried it once and that
was because i was like i had like a
well-off friend who treated treated us
to uh treated us dinner once at a
high-end restaurant and i'm just like oh
my god this is [ __ ] incredible and i
now i understand why they only give you
a few cubes of wagyu beef in like
highest restaurants right it's way too
it's like eating pure butter yeah right
and i realized this when i'm just like i
i think it was like i think it like
hacked my mind to be like okay wagyu
beef is always good it's i'm i can't get
bored of wagyu beef this is this is the
this is a5 beef right but now i i see
wagyu beef and i'm just like can i just
get a normal cut of steak please the
thing is that the normal cuts of steak
here just aren't that good yeah they're
not they're not you know unless you pay
like a good amount for it right yeah
yeah and the best steaks here are like a
lot of them so you get some really good
steaks but a lot of them are imported
yeah and they're really expensive yeah
yeah you know you're paying an absolute
premium
and again like it's like i feel wagyu
beef is a lot like you know getting like
the super fatty tuna like sushi right
it's like you can't eat that [ __ ] all
the time it's it's because you eat it
every now and then right that is good i
think i don't know how i don't know if
japan did this intentionally or not but
it's definitely a branding thing yeah
like wagyu beef is
very good branding yeah uh i don't know
how because it's all over the [ __ ]
place in japan you don't know what's wag
you what's what's constituted as wagyu
it's like it's not it's like well that's
the thing right every prefecture has its
own wagyu and they'll argue that the
other one is [ __ ] and there's the best
well that's the thing i feel that's the
biggest misconception with wagyu is that
people when people think wagyu beef they
think like a5
the best [ __ ] right but like wagyu beef
literally just means beef made in japan
yeah yeah there's like there's like low
tea wagyu as well as high tier why are
you yeah i don't know how i don't know
who if japan did this on purpose i don't
know if like like it honestly might
change honestly it might be the foreign
chefs though i think it could have been
foreign
when did it become a thing when did
wagyu beef become like well known
in like outside of japan and become like
this kind of idolized beef yeah because
i feel like that's how wagyu is
commands such high prices especially
outside of japan yeah it's because of
the branding like yeah it is you know
it's the same with you know i don't
think you know when you eat uh what's
the [ __ ] uh what's the
um really fatty uh meat called that you
get
uh
foie gras
i don't think it is
do not i think that's right how the [ __ ]
about the dark liver yeah i don't know
how the [ __ ] they've managed to charge
that's so much fun that is also just
eating pure fat i just i eat it i'm like
[ __ ] i i feel i feel like i feel i feel
like a bit sick sometimes because i was
like it's very fatty yeah it is very
very funny and kind of wagyu kind of
feels the same off how do they convince
us that foie gras was like a luxury item
and that we should pay out of our
pockets insane amounts for it i wouldn't
barely take it because it's a [ __ ]
trick to make that's why
you say that but then like you know uh
we we like killed caviar to the point
where we made them so extinct that we
made them valuable yeah like
caviar was never going to be valuable
again like the only value of caviar
comes from the fact that it's so rare
yeah like well it's similar with
lobsters right right we've made it yeah
we've made it like lobsters
lobsters used to be the cheap me that
you know they right did they uh that the
working class people used to right and
then i'm not sure why it increased in
price i don't i don't know if like the
corporations
like
uh because the working class
artificially it's been overfished yeah
it was was it over
but it's a really interesting story and
i wish i could remember the detail of it
but like i know i all i know is like
lobsters was a really cheap meat until
one day it just wasn't there
right and then it was like just to show
though that the price you know doesn't
really correlate with good tasting food
i mean you know like uh i hate to shout
out whales all the time but you know
there was some really fresh local
produce that was so cheap yeah you know
that was amazing and i still haven't had
better stuff anywhere else from like you
know from from there yeah and and you
know i don't want four girls i just want
a nice beautiful cut of meat fresh from
the day yeah and it's yeah like wagyu
beef i feel like when i first moved to
japan i could not understand why every
steak like they marketed it as like
imported from australia and i'm just
like why would you import beef when you
have wagyu here and like now living here
for like like almost two years i'm like
i get it i want a [ __ ] australian
steak man and angus beefs are [ __ ]
dope
[ __ ] it's like a very luxury thing
like there's a lot of they import a lot
of beef from like ireland and stuff too
here yeah yeah yeah ireland exports a
lot of meat to japan yeah cause like if
if you're bored of wagyu beef then just
the normal cuts of beef here just aren't
as good as uh yeah and like you can play
around a lot more with the seasonings
yeah yeah on the normal i feel with a
lot of those kinds of foods like wagyu
and like foie gras and stuff like that
it's all just like a namesake right it's
it's just like you know i don't think
anyone realistically [ __ ] everything
that's probably every week is like
where's my four grocer like you know
it's it's like pufferfish right like
fugu is also another thing where it's
like you waited just to say you ate it
yeah yeah but like no one is like
actually going to be like oh fugu is the
best tasting thing at all spoilers it's
not it literally tastes like nothing
i've had it a couple of times and i'm
just like yeah just put your life in
danger yeah i'm like i'm like this is
cool i guess i can say that i ate fish
but it's late man sometimes i just wish
i was like a [ __ ] dog bro you can
give them the same meal every single day
and they get hyped as [ __ ] for it yeah
right yo is it time for the same meal
again yo you got to be kidding me
spoiling me
every time meanwhile i have the same
meal twice in a row and i'm like i'm
living like a person
i had i had gary two days in a row what
is this i feel disgusting you know
i don't know is this like a thing that
we we did to ourselves as humans was
there once a point in time where we were
just happy to have the same meal over
and over again oh yeah i'm sure
why have we done this we probably we
probably were even as a kid right i
remember when i could just eat thai food
every night
never get bored of potatoes again
and then like i tried i tried like
japanese food for the first time i'm
just like damn i want to try this again
i tried mexican food for the first time
i'm like [ __ ] giving you my
my need of variation and uh taste has
skyrocketed since japan i could spoil me
because now i used to be content just
eating like fried chicken like four
times a week and i'd be like this is
fantastic that's the second thing i
think is overrated in japan
yeah well japanese don't really i don't
think they do fire chicken very good
here no no i think i think the koreans
definitely do it better
yeah i was gonna say man like americans
think they like have mastered fried
chicken and i'm like no the best fried
chicken i've had is from korea korean
fried chicken best in the world
they season it they don't go too
overboard in america you get way too
much seasoning yeah yeah in korea you
just get like beautiful different
variations of seasoning the yum yum
chicken is like it's not just that it's
just so good it's the perfect texture as
well where it's just like a little bit
crispy yeah it's it's it's you can't
like it's the perfect it's the perfect a
little bit crispy and like the meat's
not too wet but yeah it's not dry dry
it's just the perfect combination of
everything you'd want in a fried chicken
but also not to dog on like
fried chicken culture in london is
amazing we have such good fried chicken
in london i really disagree that's what
we have that's why we have a whole
that's why we have a whole channel
that's why there was a there was a whole
channel at one point dedicated to
reviewing fried chicken in london it's
so very [ __ ] way too greasy man no
you're going to the wrong place you're
going wrong
you're going to the wrong box you sound
like chris right now
he's going to the wrong
so place in the church we were so close
to having a podcast where we agree on
everything
no i know why chicken and lunch is
amazing man fried chicken in london it's
only amazing after you're [ __ ]
shit-faced
it's like people who
you probably had a [ __ ] local fried
chicken shop the one underneath me was
amazing the way they seasoned the
chicken [ __ ] they did barbecue wings and
i have never had barbecue wings as good
as this in my life they they were so
cheap too i don't know what they put in
it probably likes all god-awful
chemicals yeah but that [ __ ] was amazing
i've never had bbq wings that are as
good as that
and it was like it was like one pound
for like eight warring it waringly cheap
i thought it was amazing i thought that
was chicken
probably even wasn't i don't know what
it was but it was the best wings i'd had
jeez i mean like i to me the best fried
chicken
i've had in the uk is kfc like this okay
okay it's i'm not gonna say it's the
best because that's saying but it is
very good in the in the uk it is some
reason they make very good kfc it is
very good and like every fried chicken
i've had in london or every chippy or
whatever it feels like uh it feels like
a downgrade to kfc to me i feel like you
guys do chicken pretty well though can
you see in the uk is by far the best kfc
i've ever had in japan it sucks yeah oh
no japanese it's not in america it's war
crimes yeah elsewhere i assume it's just
not as good australia it's a little bit
over i'm sure there's someone from some
country that's like yeah but in in this
country it's better should i i haven't
been there so how would i know that